(Phinyo speaks in foreign language)
(intense music)
(upbeat music)
(Phinyo speaks in foreign language)
- [Narrator] When Phinyo
started as a firefighter
back in 1989, the majority of his job
was focused on fire rescue.
However, in recent years,
his job has expanded.
(Phinyo speaks in foreign language)
In recent years, new houses in Bangkok
have been built in areas
where snakes were more common,
which means snakes are
slithering their way
into houses on a more regular basis.
(upbeat music)
- Okay.
(Phinyo speaks in foreign language)
(both speaks in foreign language)
(people speak in foreign language)
(whimsical music)
(woman speaks in foreign language)
(Phinyo speaks in foreign language)
(crowd laughs)
(group speaks in foreign language)
(Phinyo speaks in foreign language)
(bright music)